until you show up and try something you
just don't know a lot of PE I think that
there are a lot of people out there that
can do a lot of things but they don't
have the guts to get on the start line
if you don't put yourself in
uncomfortable positions whether it's
starting a business learning an
instrument it doesn't have to be running
it's hard to get a lot to get any growth
there because the pressure is not on I
need a little bit of pressure and kind
of scrutiny to kind of dig deep and I
was like any one day event cool I can
show up and gut my way through it 7 days
of camping and really having to manage
the food and manage like my like be
responsible for my system was like
incredibly intimidating and
uncomfortable but that's why I did it
there was like I said that voice in my
head that was like man this is scary and
the other voice was like that's why
we're doing it okay I won but if I
didn't show up and try I definitely
wouldn't win